Seit anfang des monats ist nobelpreis zeit in der weltweiten, wissenschafts und
Forschungsfeld gibt keine größere ehrung als eben diesen preis was die diesjährigen nobelpreise mit einem
studienabbrecher oder dem jetlag beim reisen zu tun haben jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Er. Soll an all diejenigen gehen zitat die der menschheit den größten nutzen gebracht haben
So hat es mal der stifter alfred nobel selbst gesagt und zu dieser riesen großen ehre kommt auch noch ein preisgeld von knapp
einer million euro
Nobelpreis physik einstein hatte recht der nobelpreis für sie geht 2017 gleich an drei us
Physiker die auf den spuren von albert einstein wandeln sie haben jeweils mit ihren experimenten und mit ihrer grundlagenforschung zum ersten
mal den nachweis von gravitationswellen
erbracht rainer weiss kipp von und barry bärisch haben tatsächlich
Einsteins formel werk bestätigt und ihr wisst alle die messe und von gravitationswellen ist nicht nur für die
Physik welt eine sensation und auf diesen moment hatten weitaus mehr als 1000 forscherinnen und forscher hingearbeitet besonders
spannend ist dabei die geschichte von rainer weiss der tatsächlich selbst diesen einen
unfassbar wichtigen augenblick verpasst hat am 14 september vor zwei jahren um fünf uhr 51
Amerikanische art zeit lager erstens noch, im bett und war zweitens
Im urlaub weit weg von seinen beiden kilometer langen detektoren die plötzlich erzählt hatten erst dachte
Er nur das sei ein fehlalarm ein pseudo signal von seinem forschungsteam um zu testen ob er schläft nie ob die dakar
auswertung ausgearbeitet doch dann war klar dass das system nach einem update für solch einen fehlalarm noch gar nicht bereit war
Und das war der große moment der von jetzt auf gleich alles veränderte nach
jahrzehntelanger suche hatten sich
Gravitationswellen messen lassen ausgelöst durch den zusammenstoß von zwei schwarzen löchern und wie immer in der wissenschaft ist solch eine entdeckung
Noch deutlich mehr wert wenn sie wiederholt werden kann und tatsächlich auf folgende messungen
bestätigten den nachhall solcher kollisionen bei dass dafür der nobelpreis fällig war ja eigentlich
Noch eine formsache wenn man die kindheit von einer weiß kennt dann hätte man damit aber absolut nicht gerechnet
1932 wurde in berlin geboren seine familie floh dann vor den nationalsozialisten in deutschland erst nach prag dann nach
New york er bastelte fiel vor allem gern im bereich elektrotechnik doch das studium, am renommierten
langweilte ihn schnell
Ja warum nicht und so wechselte er in die physik aber auch das brachte er nicht zu ende denn er verliebte sich in eine
pianistin und sein herz für den weg nach chicago
Verrückt komplett gaga hat er später mal dazu gesagt denn
Am ende war sie weg und das studium auch
Er ging dann als labortechniker zum mrt zurück und arbeitete sich dort zum professor hoch zitat wir haben nicht groß über
gravitationswellen nachgedacht die technik war faszinierend wir hatten solchen spaß dabei sie zum funktionieren zu bringen
ein bisschen wie kinder in einem großen sandkasten
nobelpreis chemie schockgefrostet das leben als
kinofilm salmonellen sind immer mal wieder in den schlagzeilen bakterien die durch lebensmittel übertragen werden und bei menschen durchfall auslösen können also deshalb
Hühner und händlern flächen gut waschen und ordentlich durch braten oder backen ja und auch jetzt bin ich etwas vom thema abgekommen
sind sie
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes noch einmal besonders groß herausgekommen wenn die erfinder der coro mikroskopie
haben jetzt den nobelpreis bekommen das ist eine technik die die
kleinsten strukturen von leben und ihre atomaren detail sichtbar macht eben zb ein
salmonellen bakterium das eine körperzelle
infiziert oder aber andere zellen viren oder moleküle einzelne eiweiße die nicht einmal unter einem elektronenmikroskop
Zu erkennen wären wenn seine strahlung würde sie zerstören voll cool. Also büro ist dagegen dass kühe
elektronenmikroskop die objekte werden sehr schnell auf minus 180 grad celsius heruntergekühlt schockgefrostet quasi und verschiedene
zustände momentaufnahmen alles mal eines moleküls sehen so sichtbar und zwar ganz ohne farbstoffe tatsächlich eine absolut revolutionäre technik zeigt sie
forschungsteams doch beispielsweise schnappschüsse davon wie gerade ein stück erbgut kopiert wird oder eiweiße ein stückchen
herausschneiden ganz großes kino
also
Und die schauspieler sind mikroben denn die methode erlaubt
innere von molekülstrukturen zuschauen und solche großen
momentaufnahmen zusammenzufügen und das auch noch in 3d diese technik nach vorne gebracht haben die moschee
joachim frank und richard henderson und genau sie haben dafür jetzt den
nobelpreis in chemie gewonnen der schweizer hat die moschee zum beispiel hatte in den 80er jahren eine methode entwickelt durch die proben aus lebenden material
eingefroren werden können ohne dass sie dabei zerstört werden nobelpreis medizin deswegen sind wir abends müde das leben auf der erde
Ist der rotation unseres planeten angepasst so ähnlich heißt es in der pressemitteilung des nobelpreiskomitees für die erforschung der sogenannten
inneren uhr haben in diesem jahr drei
us-forscher dem medizin nobelpreis gewonnen
Wie wichtig die innere uhr ist merken wir spätestens wenn sie aus dem takt kommt zum beispiel bei einer reise durch verschiedene zeitzonen oder bei
schichtarbeit die umgebung und die innere uhr passen dann nicht mehr zusammen das ergebnis ein
fürchterlicher jetlag ist die innere uhr dauerhaft
Aus dem rhythmus plan kann dies tatsächlich krank machen das risiko für verschiedene krankheiten steigt die in ruhe?
sorgt also tatsächlich für unser überleben sie steuert hormone
Körpertemperatur und natürlich unser schlaf der verdienst der drei wissenschaftler sind die entdeckungen wie menschen tiere und pflanzen ihren rhythmus
So anpassen dass er mit dem rhythmus der erde also tag und nacht zusammen passt so die
nobelpreis jury
ihre forschung fand zum großen teil in den 70er und 80er jahren stadt ist also schon ein bisschen her und zwar an der fruchtfliege sie
identifizierten gene die die innere uhr kontrollieren eingehen dass sie entdeckten nannten sie
püriert weshalb 84 gelang es ihnen es zu isolieren und damit gingen dann die jagd auf die verschiedenen grundlagen und
funktionsweisen der inneren uhr überhaupt erst so richtig los später
entdeckten sie ein protein per das nachts ansteigt und tagsüber abnimmt also
Genau wie der 24-stündige tag nacht rhythmus und es folgten noch weitere entdeckung einer reihe von proteinen die für die steuerung der inneren uhr
zuständig sind sie alle bilden in der gesamtheit einen eigenen zyklus und zwar dadurch dass manche hammond und manche
aktivierend wirken morgens also werden alle physiologischen prozesse gestartet die uns aktiv machen abends
Sie das gegenteil und das großartige also noch einmal auf den punkt zu bringen die innere uhr produzieren selbst einen rhythmus
Sagt dem körper auf was er sich vorbereiten muss und beeinflusst hat 60 komplexe
physiologische vorgänge wie blutdruck schlafmuster oder die ausschüttung von hormonen
Ansonsten gibt es übrigens auch noch den nicht so richtigen
wirtschaftsnobelpreis der aber eben nicht auf den stifter alfred nobel zurückgeht den literatur, nobelpreis und natürlich den
Friedensnobelpreis die aber hier bei pixum glaube ich etwas dem rahmen sprengen würde nobelpreise gibt es also für die
bahnbrechenden erkenntnisse und über die wichtigsten ereignisse wie zum beispiel die gravitationswellen die bericht darüber berichten wir
Hierbei klicks um täglich wenn ihr also kein video verpassen wollt dann drückt mir her ein abo ops auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier
Geht es weiter mit dem video zum thema gravitationswellen dass wir sogar ein paar tage vor der verkündung der entdeckung online gestellt haben
Da hatten wir glaube ich eine ganz guten riecher da gab
Es also da gibt es in diesem video alle infos zum thema, also unbedingt draufklicken viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran